hello everyone and welcome to the
tournament you've all been waiting for
it's the OtterBox Norway blitz
championship and well it's really to the
main event which is the Norway LT box so
classical event and it's a 10 player
single round-robin where 10 of the some
of the 10 of the strongest players in
the world will you know face off against
each other to get better better
placement in the classical event so here
depending on what what your result will
be in the end it will mainly mean that
you will either get five white five
whites and for blacks in the classical
event or you will have to play five
times with the black pieces but there
was a lot of argument to whether it was
better to have more black pieces as then
you
we're gonna go into this but later so
let's just enjoy this game it's a very
important game as both cross and maximal
sure low growl or I believe the only
twenty nine hundred bullets players in
the world
to my knowledge maybe maybe he carves up
they're not really sure I'm gonna have
to check that but not not only that it's
a game from the final round and it will
decide the winner of the Blitz event so
without further ado let's check out the
game and also worth mentioning that the
last two blitz games they play the
maxime beaugeois grab one
so cross and has a lot to work for in
this game cross and opens with efore and
I believe it's the only game in this
event that she opened with e4 with a c5
the Sicilian and Knight to f3 and d6 and
here everyone was waiting to see if
Carson will actually challenge Maximo
Cheryl a graph to a night off as he is
known to be a you know the best I mean
the greatest night of expert in the
world but here cousin actually went for
B for the winged gamut and this it's not
like the MS game but I'm not joking here
he actually did play b4 and it's not
like when this point is on d6 and the
night isn't c6 sometimes you can
actually play this you know like the
main garena variation cross and used
against
inner kiev in the in the last year's the
world blitz championship and he won a
very nice game in the end but here it's
a very rarely played maximum immediately
captured seek a person before we have d4
okay you do have some central control as
compensation for your gambit pawn Knight
to f6 Bishop to d3 and here there is
well again you have to decide how to go
about this but Maxime blitz is out he 5
and we have a 3 and a 3 is the new move
here there actually is one game between
two 2500 players where immediately pawn
was captured with d cap frozen e5 but
here after a 3 it's a completely new
game and it's very nice I mean this is
silly non move 6 to have a completely
new game between world number one and
world number 2 blitz players we've each
capture some before and now comes Knight
captures on b4 now comes B captures on
a3
Maxime accepts the the other gambit at
pawn as well and calls and just castles
with Bishop to e7 Maxime now wants to
get his him to safety as well and now
Bishop captures on a3 now with castles
by Maxime and now Knight to c3
so just developing white is ahead of
course in development which is the only
compensation you have for the pawn and
Maxime has the well develop all of his
pieces and then start enjoying his extra
pawn with Knight to c6 and cause and
decides to capture with Knight captures
and c6 b captures and c6 and now f4
cross and needs to make something happen
as well he's still down upon and here
Maxime without any hesitation goes d5 he
offers a series of trades which will
just you know reduce matura on the board
but he gets to keep his extra pawn so
across and obliges with E 5 now going
for this trade of bishops Bishop
captures on a3 we have rook captures on
a3 and now comes Queen to b6 with check
before deciding what to do with the
knight first came to h1 you have to play
this you can block with rook f2 because
Knight to g4 was a threat but here
Knight g4 nonetheless and now
maxime is threatening Knight to have to
check which would win the exchange as
you would have to capture with the rook
so 21 guarding the f2 square with both
the rook and the Queen and here
maxime has to decide what to do if for
example Quinta III seems like a decent
idea you offer a trade of Queens you you
know reduce more mature on the board but
it would actually be a bad move and it's
it's a really nice tactic to spot
especially
as it is a blitz game but here what a
black actually just wanders the pawn so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to take advantage of this seemingly
strong Queen to e3 move I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are once again an excellent exploiter of
mixing mistakes that never actually
happened over the board and for those
who just wanna enjoy the show
night capture some d5 this is the point
and now if you capture the knight then
Bishop captures on h7 check and you lose
the Queen after rook captures here so
you will not be able to capture the
night you will have to trade Queens now
but after Queen captures anyone you will
first get your knight to safety with
nice to e7 check so the King has to move
King h8 only now you recapture here and
now you've grabbed your pawn back so
although a seemingly strong move Queen
to e3 it would actually just lose the
pawn here so Maxime went for Queen to c5
and now putting pressure on the rook
here we have rook to be three and now f5
this does create a passed pawn for
crossing but also it really blocks this
Bishop so no tricks here with Queen to
h4 are possible anymore and also it
really cements that night nicely on g4
Carlson doesn't like that so he further
weakens his King position with h3 the
knight now has to go back but now you
have to go Knights to e3 here it's it's
just better but here
maxime went nice to h6 he wanted to
bring the knight back into the game with
something like Knight to f7 to d8 to
maybe II 6 put pressure on the f4 pawn
but Carson now takes great advantage of
this nice to a4 and now you have to be
very careful with the Queen for example
if you play something like Queen before
you get a rugby 4 and the queen is lost
you don't have any squares left for your
Queen so you just have to capture on
before and the Queen would recapture so
after night before you have to go back
Queen to e7 and now calls and goes Queen
to c3 just starts pushing pressure on
blacks position and there's a really not
all that much black can do it's really
it's really hard to develop any pieces
here with Queen to c7 defending the c6
pawn and now here cross and should have
gone rook to a-1 but it's a police game
impossible to find such a move in a
blitz game because it prevents the
knight from
from coming back into the game because
Maxime went to this night to have seven
in in in the game that followed but here
if cross and went would work to a one
and night f7 doesn't work because of
night to be six this is another problem
and now you rookies under attack you
have to play something if Ruby eight and
then just Knight character Sundy five
you can actually capture because Queen
characters Queen so we'd have to trade
here but still white just you know comes
up comes out much better in this line so
after going to c7 we have Knights to see
five by crossing and the disallows
Knight to f7 the move Maxime uses to get
the knight back into the game and here
east six by Carlson pushes the knight
further back but Knight to d6 now we
have Queen to e5 by cross and and now
Queen to e7 preventing this point from
being pushed all the way to East seven
and now just look F to be one nicely
doubling Brooks here and now nice to e4
you don't want to allow any any pressure
here along with this along this diagonal
so nicely for blocking it's an excellent
square foot for the night you're
threatening to exchange here there's a
double attack here also now the Queen
can capture on c5 so Maxime is forcing
the trade here which will create a pass
for a pawn for himself with Bishop
captures an e4 with F captures on e4 and
here Carlson has a very nice move that
gives him a lot of initiative so feel
free to pause the video again and try to
find the best continuation for white
here so just a very nice position so
feel free to do so I'll give you a
couple of seconds as always for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
threat or threatener of mates and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
rook to g3 and now of course the knight
is off limits due to Queen captures and
g7 checkmate and there really isn't a
good move black can make you can develop
the rook both Queen and the rook are
guarding the B it's where you can go
here the knight and the rocker covering
that's where the knight discovering a
six so you can develop the bishop we can
go here you can go here really no good
two moves to make you would have to make
some silly moves like h6 but then comes
c4 f5 and it's just a terrible position
for black here
cross and missed at the very strong look
to g3 he played rook to b8 which it is a
lot of activity for the rook but it just
allows black to trade this rook which
wasn't able to enter the game anyway we
rope capture son b8 rook after Sun b8
and now again you cannot capture here if
you capture it's a very nice line just
each seven wins the game after the rook
moves rook captures on c8 Road captures
EA Queen captures captures and it's it's
all over not not in that particular
order but after this rook captures on c8
you would get first Queen to e6 check
not I missed Queen to f8 here but Queen
the e6 check and now it's all over now I
have to go King h8 and now Queen
captures here that's all over
so after rook captures an b8 we have
looked he ate by Maxine I'm just keeping
everything in order putting again
pressure on this e 6 pawn and here a
cross and has to go tonight's to d7 it's
just the only good move for him he has
to play it because here again black
doesn't have doesn't have a move here
you don't really have any active ideas
here you would have to go for something
like Bishop captures and e7 if you want
to do something but other than that
there's just not much to do but if
Bishop captures it then again it
captures on d7 just wins and there's not
much to do if you go here you lose the
Queen if you capture here you just go
route capture Sonny 8 with check pickup
you will either pick up the Queen or if
Queen captures this will again be
checkmate but here after Luke 2:8 cross
and did not go for this cross and
instead played f5 he wastes no time he
just goes after the black King but here
it's actually a losing blunder for
Magnus so again feel free to pause the
video and now try to find the winning
move for Maxine in this position it's uh
well it could be obvious but you know
it's it's never obvious when you're
playing against the world champion so
again feel free to have a few seconds
for those we were able to do it
congratulations I mean the knight is
hanging there on c5 so if you found
Queen Jefferson c5
you are an excellent player and hear it
there's no compensation Magnus just
blunder tonight so he tried to create
some compensation Queen to c7 attack
the bishop twice hoping for real
characters here but not Queen just goes
back we into a fete the bishop is nicely
protected and our cross and we'll
eliminate all of these pawns but still
it's no compensation and here
lastly the quicker straight away to
victory Maxime finds it Bishop to d7
just force a trade and now if you
capture here then you lose the rook here
and there's no no way you can do this
Magnus played Queen captures but now we
get rook captures nb8 and now e 7 by
Carlsen we have Queen to e8 now comes
Queen captures Sun d5 with check King to
h8 and now Queen to e5 putting pressure
on the rook here but again Maxime just
goes for the optimal idea look to b6 the
ideas rook to f6 to f7 and then pick up
this pawn he immediately finds the best
way to eliminate crossings only
advantage the e7 pawn
not advantage about the only
compensation here cousin played Queen
captures on e4 end after rook to f6
Magnus Carlsen resigned to the game yeah
or maybe his time just ran out but still
doesn't really matter as the position is
completely lost like we mentioned
whatever white plays you can start
pushing your path C pawn you will get
Luke to f7 and then rook captures here
will just be sufficient for for a nice
win sure a third win in a row in a blitz
game between these two number one and
number two in the world in my cross and
Maxime holograph and here for those of
you who are not interested in the
standings or maybe you wanna you know
check out a few more games before you
see the standings maybe skip the video
let's say a minute or or even stop
watching here but for those of you who
also want to enjoy the standings here
they are these are the standings well
these are the standings as you can see
after nine very exhausting rounds maxime
beaugeois graphic on top a point and a
half ahead of Magnus Carlsen and LaVon
onion which is you know an incredible
achievement and he now regains his
number one
well not regains but overtakes Magnus is
number one bliss player a player in the
world I believe the in live ratings
that's over 30 points of rating in blitz
so quite a quite an achievement
but there we have it max emotional
gravely von RN and Magnus Cross and
Chandra Mahmoud are of ding Liron yongi
Wesley so Fabian
which won a tournament and in the last
place Alexander Grisha so there you have
it and like I mentioned it is a somewhat
well not somewhat it is quite important
for for the how you will play the
classical event tomorrow the first
tomorrow will you have five white or and
four blacks or five blacks and for
whites which is you know really really
crazy and it is a really an interesting
event because here there are no draws if
players draw a game in the classical
event then they immediately go into
Armageddon having the same pieces so if
crossing would play against MVL and they
draw the game then cousin keeps for
example if you had the white pieces you
will keep the white pieces and then they
will go into Armageddon cousin gets I
believe seven minutes and we would get
ten minutes which is you know a new
format I believe and then Carlson has to
win with the white pieces or or he loses
the de mettre really really an
interesting approach I don't know if how
you know it will affect the games or
anything but I'm sure that if there will
be some games that will be drawn and
then there will be an Armageddon then we
might actually show in the video where I
will be covering those games both the
classical and the Armageddon game which
you know could get somewhat crazy but
yeah I just wanted to put that out there
so I do hope you enjoyed it Magnus sure
and didn't but it's very impressive how
he how he managed to get a winning
position would that be four against the
the d6 Sicilian I really just amazing
play by both of them and the result is
this beautiful game work awesome
unfortunately for him in the end
blundered the knight and c5 but you know
it happens as you know things do happen
in chess but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Anthony Cox Nathaniel Pomeroy
Roger Stevens pcw sneaks and pure
terrific for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the OtterBox
Norwich championship tomorrow starting
with the classical event I think all I
will see you soon and if you have any
other games that you've enjoyed from the
blade section do use hash tag
suggestions to suggest them
I will probably show a few more tomorrow
morning uh yeah I think I will see soon
have an excellent rest of your day